من دبي السيد
المتحدث الاقليمي باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
سيد صامويل اذا مصادر الجزيره تكشف بان
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع يتجهان
لهدنه جديده مدتها ثلاثه ايام بعد اتصالات
مع الاداره الامريكيه ما المعلومات
اذا شكرا مساء الخير يا جلال وشكرا
للاستضافه شكرا لك وشكرا
الجزيره وانا لا اريد ان ادخل في اي
تفاصيل ولكن بدون شك منذ منذ ساعات منذ
ايام كنا نحث كل الاطراف لوصول الى هدنه
الهدنه الان ما تستحق او ما يستحق الشعب
السوداني ولذلك نحن سنستمر في حذف كل
الاطراف للوصول الى هدنه واحترام الهدنه
ليس كافي
نسمع الخطابات والكلمات والوعود من
الاطراف السودانيه بالنسبه الهدنه من
اللازم ان نرى تطبيق الهدنه وبكل اسف
مروان التكرار في هذه الايام الاخيره
سمعنا وعود حول الهدنه ولكن بدون تطبيق
سمعنا بعد اي اي كلمات حول الختنه في
شاشاتكم وفي كل شاشات الاخرى اطلاق الرصاص
والانفجارات اذا نحن نتمنى ان فعلا
الاطراف ستكون
للهدنه في هذه المره قبل ساعات قليله
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي قال بانه
يتم اجلاء الدبلوماسيين والرعايه
الامريكيين من السودان لانه اصبح من
الواضح ان هناك احتمالا لتوسع الصراع
الداخلي في السودان هل لنا ان نفهم فعليا
التقييم الامريكي لهذه المرحله وما قد
ينتج عنها في الساعات المقبله
اذا صار
نتطبق الكلمات او الوعود لدينا
والالتزام لدينا بالنسبه حمايه الموظفين
للملكين الدبلوماسيين والوضع بشكل عام انا
لا اريد ان اطبق هذه الكلمات الوضع بشكل
عام لازم ندرك ان
من كل الدروس لدينا في الماضي من من ليبيا
ومن اماكن اخرى من اللازم ان نقوم بحمايه
الموظفين الامريكيين قد دبلوماسي انا
دائما اريد ان ابقى في اي بلد واشتغل معه
لفائنا واشتغل مع شركائنا واشتغل مع
المؤسسات وكل اطراف المحليه ولكن في نهايه
المطاف الحكومه الامريكيه كما لديها اي
حكمه اخرى كما راينا من كل هذه الاجراءات
لاجراء المواطنين من كل الدول من السودان
الحكومه الملكيه لديها النص الموصوليه
ولكن هذا لا يعني انها ليس
نيعه لارجع كما سمعنا من الوزير من مستشار
الامن القومي لدينا النيه للارجاع الى
للرجاء الى السودان في اسرع وقت ممكن
طبعا تابعت اليوم ما قالته الخارجيه
تحديدا وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي بانه نسق
مع اسرائيل ما يسميها وساطه محتمله في
السودان تقودها تل ابيب هل لك ان تطلعنا
على تفاصيل ربما تتعلق بهذا التنسيق ما
بين الجانب الامريكي والجانب الاسرائيلي
فيما يتعلق بما تقول اسرائيل بانها وساطه
في السودان بين الجنرلين
ليس لدي اي معلومات عن ذلك من الجانب
الامريكي لازم احيلك الى الحكومه
الاسرائيليه التي تحدث عن هذه الامور
الولد المتحده ترى ان من اللازم من
المجتمع الدولي يتحدث ويتكلم مع الاطراف
الفلانيه بصوت واحد بدون اي فجوه امامنا
بدون اي اختلافات من اللازم ان نتكلم بشكل
صائمه وبصوت واحد من الولايات المتحده من
الدوله الاوروبيه من الدوله الخليجيه من
الامم المتحده من جامعه العربيه من ايجاد
من الاتحاد الافريقي من الازمه كنا
نتكلموا بصوت واهل من اجل الشعب السوداني
الذي هم يعانوه الان من استمرار هذا
الصراع اذا بدون شك نحن نشجع كل دول كل
دول بدون استثناء التي لديها تواصل مع
الاطراف السودانيه لتكون نفس الشيء حان
الوقت الان يوقف اطلاق نار فورا
خلال لقائه الوزير بلنكن مع وزير الخارجيه
الكيمي الفريد متوه الاخير عبر عن قلقه من
اي تدخل خارجي في السودان ومن توسع هذا
الصراع الى الى دول اخرى ما الرساله التي
تفهمونها من هذا التصريح
الرساله من الجانب الامريكي ليس من الممكن
ان يتحدث باسم
الوزير الكيني بالنسبه مقاله ولكن من جانب
الولايات المتحده كنا نقول منذ منذ زمان
ان اي تداخل الاجنبي ستفاقم الامور في
السودان والله نريد ان نرى اي طرف اجنبي
التدخل في السودان نحن ندرك ان ومن الازمه
المجتمع الدولي كل الدول تدركنا اي حل
دائم لازم يكون حال السوداني سوداني هل
بين اطراف السودانيه نحن الان نرى في
شاشاتكم القتال بين الجيش السوداني وقوه
الدعم السريع هذا الطرفين سودانيين
الاثنين اذن من اللازم ان يكون اي حل بين
السودانيين ونحن ضد اي تدخل اجنبي ليس
لدينا او ليس لدينا اي مناقشه مع اي من
حلفائنا وشركائنا حول اي تداخل اجنبي في
السودان شكرا لك السيد صامويل المتحدث
الاقليمي باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه في دبي